[Musik]
ich begrüße sie das historische museum
bern
das ist eine schatzkammer und heute
haben wir sie ganz für uns
naja fast ich treffe nämlich gleich
verrät hg er ist ein kurde aus dem
norden syriens und hier museum ist etwas
ganz besonderes
menschen die aus ihrer heimat geflüchtet
sind führen durch die sammlung so auch
von hat hardy er wird mir seine
lieblings objekte zeigen und sagen
weshalb sie ihn so am herzen liegen
kommen sie also mit
[Musik]
ich bin von hawke und bin kultur aus
syrien ich bin seit er selbst den wir
2015 mitte sogenannte flüchtlinge label
die balkanroute in der schweizer und
gekommen
[Musik]
wie kommt es dazu dass sie hier im
historischen museum führungen anbieten
ja ich habe mir schon längst beschlossen
dass ich die rolle ausdrucken brauche
einfach übernehmen
das habe ich seit auch 2018 eine
anlaufstelle für arabisch und kurdisch
sprechen eine person gegründet das heißt
integrationsbetriebe und über dieses
projekt ist eine von der projektleiterin
auf mich zugekommen und mich dem projekt
vorgestellt ob ich mitmachen
für mich war hier vor ort genau für mich
war ganz klar dass man definitiv mit
weil es bietet mit genau so eine
plattform dass ich mit den menschen
einfach in kontakt komme und meine sicht
besser erzählen kann
also das ist für sie wirklich ein
herzensprojekt definitiv definitiv das
mache ich wirklich von ganzem herzen
weil es bietet mit genau den plattform
dass ich quasi mit den menschen in
kontakt komme aber auf augenhöhe und
nicht einfach aus der armen migranten
man ihnen helfen muss sondern wirklich
fließen darf augen hören sie können den
leuten etwas geeignet von mir dass ich
nicht immer der arme bin sondern
wirklich auch etwas machen kann und so
fühle ich mich sehr wohl in dieser rolle
[Musik]
jetzt zeige ich ihnen vor ich
normalerweise meiner führung einfach
straße ist eigentlich mehr wenn ich
jetzt eine große orientalisches sammlung
aber ich beginne ganz gerne in einem
ganz besonderen raum damit für ein
großer bedeutung hat nämlich aber es
kommt ihnen das sicher bekommt vom
hafthaus wie eine moschee ja der pläne
die das ist eine moschee aber so eine
moderne musche von uns selber sehr viel
von von owlient ja aber das ist ja schon
sehr erstaunlich dass sind diesen
historischen museum in bern eine moschee
ist nicht also hat sich das nicht sehr
erstaunt dass ich herkomm durch selig
aber die gebäude von außen immer gesehen
ich hab nicht sicher dann einfach ein
kam ich ich war sehr erstaunt dass
hinter dieser gruppe eine moschee drin
ist aber das hat mich doch gefreut weil
ich von der falschen dass auch eine
moschee in eine panische historische
museum gibt ja aber das ist ja nur quasi
eine attrappe das wird die nicht als
moschee verwendet oder und sind diese
dinge hier die ganzen verzierung sind
die echt ja sind eigentlich ursprünglich
echt aber es wurde einfach nachträglich
einfach hier gemacht es war ja früher
auch so und hier wurde war neu gebraucht
ach so aber was mich sicher auch es gibt
etwas was mich einfach da stört weil
wissen ja einen friedlichen ort quasi
moschee wo man wird nur zum beten geht
aber es gibt so viele einfach schwerte
einfach hier
das hat mich eben auch gewundert
weswegen hier drin schwerter ausgestellt
werden
ja dass es auch für mich war meine frage
wie das sollte eigentlich auch nicht so
sein aber es die sammlung die gesamte
sammlung gehörte henri moser und die
kann man ja nicht überall verteilen
dieser deshalb hat man das große raum
aus moschee verwendet aber doch einfach
die all diesen kult oder in sachen noch
rein geht aber jetzt müssen wir doch
sagen also es ist ja erstaunlich eine
moschee dann schwerter und so wer war
dieser händler sagen
der händler muss ist hier schon eine
große sammlung orientalischer sammler da
kommt auch schon raus und er hat
wirklich eine große seine große liebe
war eigentlich sachen zusammen er kommt
aus einer
und das industrie familie und zwar in
einfach machbar zum beispiel dieser
reisen zu machen also wieder schießen
finanzen aber ganz sauber war ja nicht
immer wir die sachen bekommen hat
nämlich weil er hat ja nicht immer
direkt die sachen bekommen sondern über
händler
und diese hände haben ja die sache nicht
ganz sauber einfach hingekriegt
daher aber trotzdem ist am schluss
einfach jeder angekommen
es wurde 1914 an technische historische
museum nach dem nachdem schaffhausen
einfach geweigert hat dieser die
sammlung zurücknehmen und am 1922 wurde
im bernischen also ich museum eröffnet
und sagen sie mal was bedeutet das für
sie persönlich ihre führung jeweils in
einer moschee zu beginnen
es ist ein nicht ganz groß aber es für
mich ich bin da weil diese moschee
bezieht sich auf einen anderen objekte
vorstellen möchte weil es eigentlich das
gehört nicht unbedingt zu meinen
objekten
aber es gehört zu meinem kleinen rätsel
in meiner führung und dort werden wir
irgendwann wieder drauf kommen wieso ich
ja überhaupt ab jetzt wissen wir gleich
zu unseren ersten objekt
[Musik]
wie haben sie diese objekte ausgewählt
nachweis im prinzip ja ich habe was ich
durfte ja die objekte ganz frei einfach
befehlen welche ich erwähnen möchte aber
für mich war ganz wichtig wenn ich
einfach objekten realismus in ganz
persönlichen bezug zu meinem geschichte
haben und so habe ich ein paar objekte
einfach gewählt und er erst englisch
diesem schulz heißen traum vom berg der
eskorte für die bürgermeister und ich
habe mich so schultheiß bürger wenn euer
ja und ich habe mich einfach für demel
einfach entschieden weil es wird sich
sie auf thema macht und weshalb genau
der das selbst schon von diesem barocken
stil und weiter als es wahrscheinlich
nicht so unbedingt ihre kultur zu kultur
rein gar nicht aber für mich ist war
auch am anfang ich dachte ist es eine
machtposition der mitte menschen drauf
sitzt seine macht zeigen möchte aber als
ich erfahren habe wieso es verbietet
wichtigste grund hinter diesen schulz
heißt dass es so breit ist und man ist
hat mich sehr erstaunt und wollte
unbedingt einfach zeigen in einführung
und was ist denn der grund der grund ist
das egal wer darauf sitzt sieht nach
ganz klein aus hier ist ein zeichen dass
die macht und die verantwortung immer
über der person ist und nicht umgekehrt
macht ist eine verantwortung genau ein
verantwortung zu übernehmen und seitdem
halte ich sehr gern ein paar bekannten
präsident dann einfach geschenkt weil
irgendwie haben sie auch ihren rollen
einfach vergessen muss wieder raus und
so war es sehe nun nicht einfach
mächtigste und könig sind und das
ausnützen und weshalb ist für sie macht
so ein wichtiges thema hängt das auch
mit zu gehen zusammen ist hängt schon
mit schülern und allgemein nicht nur im
süden sondern auch anderen ländern wie
sehr ihn jahren bekannten länder was
passiert wenn man die macht ausnützt und
deshalb die macht ist ein sehr wichtiges
ist und soll nicht jeder einfach
bekommen soll nicht jeder bekommt was
sagen sie denn jeweils den leuten wenn
sie hier sind ja ich frage auch immer
meine leute die meine führung sehen ob
sie die macht einfach übernehmen
jedoch des schultheißen thron sitzen
aber erstaunlicherweise willen immer
einfach drauf sitzen weil sie merken
hier das wie wichtig ist und wie groß
ist die verantwortung zu übernehmen weil
das hat es auch der sinn hinter diese
schuld heißt ohne dass die macht und die
verantwortung über das versagen dass man
das richtig spürt würden sie sagen das
ist etwas typisch schweizerisches dass
man nicht unbedingt die macht übernehmen
tja und wenn schon dann einfach teilen
und nicht mehr nur allein einfach die
macht übernehmen wie auch zum beispiel
bundesrat endlich sie verteilen sich auf
acht menschen und nicht nur eine einzige
und wie ist es bei ihnen würden sie
gerne die macht übernehmen ja sehr gern
er hatte immer auch so trübe wie was ich
einfach später werde und in syrien
wollen mein großer traum eigentlich
irgendwann das schwedische präsident zu
werden wird ja ganz ganz bestimmt sehr
schön und das hat sich jetzt immer noch
weiter gegeben und ich möchte schon auch
in der schweiz an diesem zwang noch
weiter sie träumen und wenn diesen traum
weiter ja aber nicht dass süßes und
seiner schweizer trauen
es gibt ja das war jetzt keine einziges
präsident sondern auch genau und
vielleicht mal eins von diesen acht
werden und dabei einfach irgendetwas
verändern
da sind wir sehr gespannt ja genau
wir bleiben aber jetzt beim thema macht
bleiben normalerweise bei thema und
macht aber ich zeige ganz etwas anders
aber das bezieht sich auch auf gemacht
und es wäre in diesem raum hier
wie sie sehen hier einfach sind teil
versiegelte briefe verträge ja wichtige
sachen ja und was hat das für sie jetzt
mit macht konkret zu tun genau das geht
ja dass ich persönlich einfach hier
reinkam
ich fahre am ersten blick sehr schön
sehr erstaunt nicht aber es hat mich
auch gleich gleichzeitiger traurig
gemacht deswegen weil keine aus meinem
war nur ein einziges funktion aus diesen
drei materialien also aus papier da
haben sehr segel und die schrift oder
wachs papier und die religion er war
eigentlich eine methode eine strafe
methode von der regierung dass sie die
leute somit einfach wirtschaftlich
bestraft hat wenn sie zum beispiel
irgendwie eine laden hat den oder ein
haus und sie gebe politisch engagiert
waren
dann wurden sie ist ob politisch oder
wirtschaftlich bestrafen indem sie
einfach es hieß einfach rotes
versiegelung mit irgend einem blatt
papier und verwachsen und so versiegelt
es war einfach sehr klein und sehr
schwach man konnte sehr leicht
auseinander also damit hat die regierung
dann diesen laden geschlossen genauso
hat es los und die strafe war dieser
schwache einfach versiegelung
auseinander zu nehmen war einfach sehr
sehr sehr hart und dann hat sie das
besonders traurig gestimmt weil sie
gesehen haben sie also weil sie das so
weil es für mich war einfach wieso muss
man einfach diesen sachen wieso darf man
nicht so schön verwenden wieso muss man
das immer böse verwenden
ja das hat mich sehr deshalb war bisher
traurig gemacht haben sie das selber
erlebt nein ich hatte leider nichts
manchmal versiegeln und es war ja es ist
sich politisch zu engagieren ist es
nicht so einfache sache bei uns weil zum
beispiel einer von meinem onkel war vor
26 jahren sehr politisch engagiert und
der seitdem verschwunden und niemand
weiß etwas
neben des opfers war nicht so eine
leichte sache oder eine einfache aufgabe
sich politisch zu engagieren
sie sagen jetzt sie hatten nichts zu
versiegeln also was für einer familie
kommen sie denn ich komme schon von 1
ganz ohne komische familien not in
syrien und ich hatte ja nichts nicht nur
deshalb sondern weil ich starten los war
alles wurde genau dieser vor
staatenlosen quote würde ich jetzt bei
uns im dritten themen noch erweitern
teilnehmen hier in diesem raum hier
genau wir bleiben da aber bevor sie etwa
hinschauen ich möchte aber ganz große
frage
tun sie aber normalerweise abstimmen
und wie finden sie die methode ja ich
stimme ob ich finde es ganz bequem ich
krieg den brief nach hause geschickt ich
habe die informationen dazu und kann es
einfach ausfüllen ich finde das in
ordnung ja ja ich durfte ja in meinem
leben nie abstimmen weil sie in syrien
ebner sauer darüber starten los ich
hatte nur ein blatt papier und stand
drauf ausländer darf nicht reisen
deshalb durfte ja nicht abstimmen aber
wenn ich mal abstimmen führte und auf
diesen schultheiß thron sitzen darf
würde ich mich für diese methode einfach
entscheiden
deswegen was ist daran den speziell dass
der albatros quasi vom wenn man dort
haben etwa die früher die menschen
durften einfach so abstimmen mit süßen
kugeln dann bekam eine goldene und eine
silberne kugel 7 1 und gold heißt ja so
konnten die kandidaten quasi ihren namen
tauschen einfach lassen und dann durfte
man so abstimmen und was finden sie
jetzt daran so toll wenn nicht die
kugeln mir geht es darum helfer hier
nicht um das denkt sondern etwas also
nicht im detail wie das funktionale war
auch nicht es geht darum dass man sich
an diesem tag einfach trifft und
miteinander dem austausch kommt weil das
für mich einfach wichtig mit diesem
menschen kontakt wenn man überall war
etwas wichtiges einfach entscheidet dass
man vorher miteinander diskutiert weil
an diesem tag mussten die menschen sich
an einem tag einfach zu oft von den
gleichen nenner genau die männer
wir sprechen hier über demokratie aber
die demokratie hat immer noch einfach so
schaffte als früher dürften ja auch
schatten zeigen weil früher dürften ja
auch die armen menschen und die bauer
familie nicht abstimmen die frauen
sowieso und momentan dürfen darf man
nicht auch mittlere hätten nicht alle
dürfen mitreden und muss ja nicht auch
beim wichtigen thema sein hab ich selber
auch kleinen dingen was zum beispiel das
alltagsbetrieb zum beispiel integration
darf man auch nicht mitreden obwohl sie
so stark betrifft und sie daher ein
experte sind werden sie daraus
geschlossen
ja ich denn das an für sie ja das für
ich fühle ich mich nicht so gut weil ich
mir erklären
meine bedürfnisse kenne ich besser und
ich werde euch wohl einfach nie richtig
gefreut wenn schon wieder auch die
antwort muss seriös angenommen zb wie
vor einfach etwa zwei jahre nicht an
einer integrations austausch dort haben
sich die organisationen und projekten
freiwillige von den sich versammelt und
mit erzählt dass sie einfach wie sie
mitten wie sie die früher bloß nicht von
flüchtlingen besser ansprechen wie sie
sich verbessern
aber komischerweise ich wurde einziger
mensch mit migrationhintergrund dort und
sie haben mich nicht eingeladen sondern
ich habe die freiwillig dorthin gelangen
ich mir freiwillig dorthin gegangen weil
ich das sägen wolfach die infos einfach
gesehen also wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe dann ist es für sie eben ganz
wichtig dass die leute zusammenkommen
und zwar egal wie sie denken dass die
leute eben mit migrationshintergrund usw
dass ich da etwas vermischt dass man die
meinungen aus der genau weil
normalerweise tut man tun sie sicher
auch mit den kollegen freunde
austauschen
aber sie bleiben immer in diesen engen
preis und mit den leuten die meine
meinung genau sie sind einfach ein
geringer preis und die haben mehr oder
wenn ihr die gleiche meinung und ihre
informationsquellen sind auch mehr oder
weniger die gleichen kontrollen und die
kann man nicht sich schon schnell
täuschen wenn man nicht wirklich
hinschaut und genauso eine beispiel wie
man sich schnell täuschen kann zeige ich
ihnen
bei uns im vierten objekt werde jetzt
sehr froh hier oben wie jetzt den leader
zu rücken orientalische versammlung wie
den gleichen eine persische empfangen zu
ändern
[Musik]
ja wir sind ja jetzt hessische
empfangszimmer im wenige historische
museum
das ist erstaunlich dass hier
erstaunlich aber möchte ich gerne
fachwissen fällt ihnen ihr etwas auf in
diesem raum also es fällt mir natürlich
auf dass es erstaunlich ist dass das
hier gibt sonst
ich sehe arabische schriftzeichen ich
sie elemente die man in einer moschee
finden kann und dann ist es natürlich
erstaunlich dass so kunstform durch
möchte liegenden jugendstil mit ebenso
orient ornamenten weiß ich nicht ja
stimmt es ist schon erstaunlich weil es
steht für eine plötzliche empfangen aber
das ist gar keine persischen ford sind
sondern sondern eine große sammlung die
einfach in einen raum ist und so war zum
beispiel
es sieht wie eine schmiede aus aber das
ist keine schwäche sondern das
wichtigste teil in eine moschee war
eigentlich immer nach mekka gerichtet
ist unter ihm aufgestellt und bietet
vorbetet genau dann quasi alle gläubigen
nach der persische stil hier zum zweiten
wollen ist es auch ein zweites teil von
einem muss das gleiche teil aber nach
marokkanische algerische stehen von
diesem gebiet hier hinter uns befindet
noch ein drittes wand und das waren auch
es ist wieder von den dritten muschel
und dort steht auch etwas geschehe horx
höchstes meine gemeinde gott und das
kommt einfach aus der osmanische bei
einfach reich also das heißt in diesem
persischen empfangszimmer wurden jetzt
einfach elemente von verschiedenen
moscheen zusammen genau das geht noch
weiter es noch nicht fertig es gibt hier
eine wand und mit der fenster diese wann
ist es gehört meinem empfangszimmer und
nicht irgendwelche im vorzimmer sondern
eine frauen in form
also das heißt es ist eigentlich das
einzige objekt in diesem raum dass
tatsächlich in einem empfangszimmer wäre
geht noch weiter es gibt aber die kupfer
gekommen will es ist auch von einem
hammer war früher habe der mann keinen
strom und man hat die welt wie kann man
eigentlich nicht rein bringen und so hat
man die idee entwickelt mit dem
leuchtend einfach glas dass mir ein
fachlich drei tageslicht rein genau es
wird jetzt ein bisschen komplizierter
aber gibt auch noch was dazu gehört die
drei bilder sind also titel genau die
drei bände die drei bildet die wir
zeichen genau die drei sachen die im
islam verboten sind
musik oder tanzen oder singen alkohol
trinken oder menschen und jede zeichen
und jetzt fragen sich wieso jetzt zu all
diesen sachen einer raum- und das ist
eigentlich eine persische empfangszimmer
aber es passt gar nicht zusammen
das sind für helle moser war eigentlich
dass dieser zimmer 0 völlig exotisch
aussieht also es gibt den eindruck als
ihre ästhetische empfangszimmer mit
rollen
aber wenn man vorne ließ dann ließ man
ja presseempfang zimmer kann man nach
hause gehen und sagen ich war in eine
persische empfangszimmer dass das stimmt
aber gar nicht weil man bekommt immer
die infos aus orient und man fragt ja
fast nie nach und man glaubt einfach
dran was gerade im fernseher kommt oder
im internet dann denkt man ja und es
dass es geht ihnen also irgendwie um
täuschung und vorurteile
ja genau deshalb sehe ich mich auch so
speziell wie eine typische oder an
aber dabei fühle ich mich sehr unwohl in
diesem kleinen aber weshalb ziehen sie
ist dann an wenn sie sich nicht wohl
fühlen weil ich weiß die menschenbilder
sofort ein bild von mir als einen
typischen türken aber gerade nach der
führung merken sie es ein richtig
kleiner spielen gar keine rolle weil ich
bin sondern wirklich in meinem einfach
ich als mensch zähle ich und das bild
vom kleider bleibt gar nicht bei den
menschen was ich erzählt haben das heißt
sie wollen eigentlich mit den besuchern
spielen und mit ihren toren das ist
einlass ist immer seine spielt weil sie
so aussehen sind alle sehr erstaunt so
speziell
aber am schluss das ist die kleider sind
gar nicht mehr so wichtig wie ich
aussehe
was sie sehen mich als jemand anderes
als sie am anfang gesehen
[Musik]
wie gesagt ja wir alle die führung
machen kommen aus ganz unterschiedliche
hintergründe
aber ich persönlich würde jetzt gerne
meine heimat zeigt also hintergründe sie
man als sind alles letztlich mit genau
aber gleich möchte ich ihnen fragen was
bedeutet ihnen das bedeutet für sie
heimat
ja das ist eine schwierige frage
ich würde sagen ich könnte es nicht an
ort nennen es ist für mich bestimmt ein
gefühl und hängt für mich mit personen
zusammen ja so könnte ich es kurz fassen
genaues sehr spannender sie sagen weil
ich von jedem moment zu anderen das
begriff heimat bedeutet anders und
deshalb zeige ich ihnen mein heimaten
wieso sieht meine heimat ist es gerade
da das ist aber bern genau sie haben es
gerade schnell herausgefunden dass es
präsentiere ich ihm ganz stolz mein heim
wo ich mich zu hause fühle ich mich wohl
fühle und hier wo ich jedes mal wenn ich
einfach unterwegs bin und wieder zurück
über die brücke wirklich mal eben nicht
sieht mit dem zug zurück komme fühle ich
mich endlich zu hause angekommen kann
ich endlich ein atmen weil ich weiß ich
bin jetzt zu hause ja und wenn es jetzt
so erzählen was was löst das denn in
ihnen aus wenn sie sagen hier das ist
ihre heimat wenn sie das so sehen
juli ins malt nervös wenn ich da stehen
und sie präsentiere ich bekommen wir so
wird die ganze hand weil ich stehe voll
man im heimat und das bei mir viele
gefühle viele emotionen
ich bin eher in dieser stadt eigentlich
kann ich sehr gut sagen ich bin in
dieser stadt verliebt ich finde das ja
schon sehr erstaunlich weil sie haben ja
bestimmt noch familie in syrien oder
klar ich habe noch meine motor noch ein
paar geschwister in syrien
aber es für mich kein
sondern eher ein herkunft wenn wir
bedenken syrien immer noch ein konflikt
hat wie schauen sie auf ihre herkunft
zurück ja sehr traurig ist es klar weges
als meine herkunft ich mir sehr traurig
wie die situation dort ist aber ich kann
gar nicht dort ändern und ich bin auch
ich muss einfach nur zuschauen wie es ja
auch was passiert dort und ich kann auch
gar nicht helfen weil die situation ist
es genug schwierig doch wie geht es in
ihrer familie also anders als gut
ja es ist gar nicht so schön sie wissen
ja nicht wie es jetzt weiter geht ja was
jetzt natürlich interessant ist wenn sie
das so sagen und auch in ihrem
unglaublich guten deutsch eben obwohl
sie noch nicht so lange hier sind man
nennt sie ja auch einen vorzeige
migranten was gibt ihm das für ein
gefühl wenn sie das zuhören von außen
ich bin schon mehr oder weniger schon
stolz drauf dass ich so einfach dass
mich so benennen und mitteldeutschland
ich ja es ist etwas selbstverständlich
ist wenn ich ihn einfach etwas machen
möchte dann muss ich einfach meinen
deutschen dann muss ich deutsch können
und das ist eigentlich die der schlüssel
für alles auch einher
und das heißt sie wollen auch nicht
unbedingt nach syrien zurück gehen nein
auf gar keinen fall es gibt nur eine
ausnahme wenn das ich nach süden geht es
zum reisen und nicht zurückgehen sondern
nur leise nur aus einem grund und zwar
dass ich nochmal es das ziel dessen
wieder einfach weil sie das so sehr
mögen genau man will einfach nicht genau
das gleiche bekommen
ganz herzlichen dank für diese führung
und diese ganzen einblicke sehr gerne
sehr gern das habe ich gerne gemacht
[Musik]
auch menschen aus afghanistan iran
eritrea und tschetschenien führen durch
das historische museum in bern
jeder mit seinem eigenen blick auf das
was wir versammlungs würdig halten und
jeder mit ihrer eigenen geschichte
[Musik]